is business about logic or emotion so i
got a great question for one of my
youtube viewers steve love you guys who
wrote in to say
evan i was recently turned down for a
restaurant franchise i gave them
population statistics mls data i made an
emotional appeal to how dedicated it
would be to success what went wrong what
is the balance between logic and emotion
in a business proposal so great question
steve and i'm sorry that this didn't
work out for you but
hopefully this contributes to you
finding eventually what is your right
path and what the right business is for
you
business is about both it's about logic
and emotions okay
there aren't too many people who make
decisions only on logic
and make decisions only on emotion it's
a combination now when dealing with a
franchise here's what you have to
understand okay why did you get turned
down
franchises
the good ones at least they plan out
years in advance where they want to go
right they start with their one location
they usually build satellite locations
and then they grow out from there they
look at the markets they want to be in
and they make a decision based on that
and they know like the good ones know
years in advance if they don't if
franchises are just willing to accept
anybody who comes in you don't want to
be a part of that organization because
it's going to be pretty low quality
you have an mls data population data all
that stuff doesn't matter because they
should already know where they want to
be
and you picked a market that's not on
their timetable
so it's really hard to change them once
they've already laid out their three
five year plan you want to add this
market that's not part of their plan
that makes it really difficult that's a
that's a you know logical decision that
you're trying to turn a whole ship
around this makes it harder than for
them to say yes
so what i would consider doing and this
is a personal decision look at where
their roadmap is going
right so they have x number of locations
now they want to grow to these cities go
to that city
be a franchisee there now that may mean
uprooting your family i don't know if
you want to do that i don't know if
you're ready to commit to that or not
it's a personal decision
but they should be much more willing to
say yes to you moving to a market that
they want to expand to that's already on
their map than you trying to do all this
from scratch and say hey come to this
city on top of that then
it's do they like you or not right if
you're willing to move to whatever city
and have them go there
do they want you to be the franchisee
there or not
usually it's going to be a combination
what franchises look for one do you have
financial security
right what what what's your background
do you have money in the bank are you
gonna be around in five years
right they want to know all that
so do you have the financial security to
launch this thing and two is your your
personality you know your your demeanor
your values do you fit in with the
company or not so if you're you're
willing to move to the city and you have
the financial backing to put it all in
together
and they still say no
then they just don't like you there's
something about you that they don't like
for whatever reason and you know if i
were you i wouldn't want to be part of
that organization either i want to move
on to something else
now one way you may be able to sweeten
the deal if they're worried about your
financial situation or you didn't pass
all the numbers make it a little sweeter
for them maybe you double the franchise
free at the start and you have reduced
payments every month until you make that
amount back right like show them you're
really committed to this beyond just
saying hey i'm really committed i want
to make it a success because everybody
will come in and say that right they're
going to come in and say
oh i'm going to try and i hope it goes
well right like everyone can say they're
committed but here you're putting your
money where your mouth is
so
those are my suggestions i hope that
works for your business for those of you
watching if you've had success
in the franchising business or if you
have thoughts that might help add to
this story please leave in the comments
below i'd love to hear from you give it
a thumbs up if you like this video click
on my face subscribe to the channel
thank you so much i'll see you soon